we bought that for the neck because we
thought the neck could use them but we
didn't realize that it works sort of
ugly way of it she is not an attractive
she's unattractive
yeah unfortunate John Koch heir John
Koch antiques
I'm Kevin Creighton I'm the manager of
John Koch antiques we're an antique shop
on the Upper West Side of Manhattan and
we specialize in the sex for TV and
movies we buy a state for the most part
so we get people's whole lives we were
sort of spilled about on the floor and
other dealers would come and with them
came the set decorators and production
designers that did the television shows
and movies the first of which was
probably Woody Allen Sex in the City
the knick blacklist vinyl The Good Wife
Mad Men Gotham wolf of Wall Street's
Ugly Betty Madam Secretary deuce with
James Franco Saturday Night Live I think
we've done almost every the ice storm
admissions girl on a train Gossip Girl
DB goes down other than that it's just
the people that come in that you really
surprise that like Lucy K and he
actually asked to use the stores
location for a season finale last year
and then the producer came over to me
said Louie wants to know I feel like
doing a favor and being the show I want
to get there for her okay which is 495
okay I don't want to get it I was
working on louis c.k shows it's just
like an honor you know I would do it for
free
we have cut that
you